Now that we have
a good grasp on TLS,
let's talk about signatures.
I mentioned certificate
authorities earlier
and the job is to
sign certificates.
But what does it mean?
And why would anyone want
a signed certificate?
When we say someone
has signed a document,
we mean that the
certificate authority
has reviewed and verified the
contents of that document.
The purpose is to have
some kind of proof
that the document was seen, or
even created by that entity.
Just like signing your
name on a document
is legal proof that
you saw that document,
a server can do the same thing
with a digital signature.
When a server signs a
document and encrypts it
with their private key,
they give that back
as a signed document.
Since only the holder
of the private key
is able to encrypt
documents, you
know the document you
received is exactly the same
as the one the server sent.
However, documents can
become fairly large.
Think of DVD
images, for example.
And encrypting and
decrypting takes a long time
with asymmetric cyphers.
That's why instead of encrypting
the entire document itself,
just the hash of the
document is encrypted.
If you want to check if
the signature is valid,
you would decrypt the
signature and hash
the document yourself to see
if those two values match.
This way we know that
the document we received
is exactly the same as
when the server sent it.
If the document was
changed midflight,
the hash would not
match the one provided
by the server as a signature.
This is called an
invalid signature.